♪
>> Bret: IT IS FRIDAY, YOU
KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS,
NOTABLE QUOTABLES.
>> I MANAGED TO GET HIM WITH
ONE HAND ON THE GUN AND THEN
I GRABBED IT FROM HIM, AND I
THREW IT OVER THE COUNTER
TOP.
>> IT WAS A GRUESOME SCENE.
REALLY BAD OUT THERE.
I COULDN'T BELIEVE WHAT I
SEEN, MAN.
OH, MAN, EVERYBODY ALL THESE
PEOPLE ON THE STREETS
GETTING HIT ONE BY ONE.
>> TO BE IN THAT DUGOUT
WHERE THEY STILL MARKED THE
BULLET HOLES THERE.
>> WE ARE VINDICATED.
WE'RE VALIDATED.
WE'RE NOT SHUTTING UP.
AND WE ARE NOT GOING AWAY.
>> I'M GOING TO BE ON
ANOTHER NETWORK TOMORROW
THAT THINKS I SHOULD BE IN
JAIL.
>> THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS.
>> KIM JONG UN WAS -- HE
REALLY HAS BEEN VERY OPEN,
VERY HONORABLE.
>> FACTS ARE FACTS AND
FICTION IS FICTION.
AND A LIE DOESN'T BECOME
TRUTH JUST BECAUSE IT
APPEARS ON THE FRONT PAGE OF
THE NEWSPAPER.
>> IT'S PRETTY HISTORIC
SENDING SECRETARY OF STATE
TO THE FLOOR WITHOUT A
POSITIVE RECOMMENDATION.
>> I HAVE CHANGED MY MIND.
>> IN THE WHITE HOUSE THEY
CALL HIM THE CANDY MAN.
>> I SAID TO DR. JACKSON
WHAT DO YOU NEED IT FOR?
I SAID WHAT DO YOU NEED THIS
FOR?
BUT I SAID WHAT DO YOU NEED
IT FOR.
I SAID TO HIM WHAT DO YOU
NEED IT FOR?
>> I DON'T EVEN KNOW.
>> I LIKE HIM A LOT.
WE DO HAVE A VERY SPECIAL
RELATIONSHIP.
WE HAVE TO MAKE HIM PERFECT.
HE IS PERFECT.
>> LOOK HOW NICE YOUR
PARENTS.
THEY ARE NOT SCREAMING AND
GOING WILD.
>> I HAVE KNOWN KANYE A
LITTLE BIT.
I GET ALONG WITH KANYE.